I give my life for you you give your
life for me nobody gets left behind
I always want to tell this story and I
don't want it to get old because I feel
like I'm gonna keep telling the story it
just happened recently but I met a white
man in England and he stopped me at a
convention and he said I come from a
very racist family very very racist he
said I watched all of season one and I
didn't realize you were black until the
end and he didn't mean he didn't see my
color because we have to see each
other's differences right and love
because of them but he meant I saw
myself in you completely and he said in
the journey that I went on really
changed me and now I feel like I can
teach my kids and I can finally break
the cycle of racism in my family and
when I started crying
of course at what he was like oh I
didn't mean to make you cry I was like
are you kidding me you know that that's
the most amazing thing there's a fan
whose name is last and we were in in Las
Vegas at the Star Trek convention there
and you know I wear the white uniform
and he showed up he's a Latin is a
Latino gay man and he showed up in the
white uniform and it meant a lot to me
and meant a lot to him so I love that's
one of my favorite lines so there was
one guy the very first guy that ever
recognized me I've only had like three
that are like are you there like I'm a
big Star Trek fan and he we were filming
and he I was walking back from the gym
and he like was like hey are you Ethan
and he was so sweet and it was my very
first to recognize me this box so
probably that I I feel like it but you
know there's always when we work on
something like Star Trek that goes back
so many decades that has such a vast
you don't there's an added pressure to
not let anyone down and of course I'm
playing a character that semi iconic and
already created in the 60s by someone
else which I have to honor and I had a
blast doing so I don't want to let it I
don't want to disappoint the fans like
the fans are like always in the back of
my head I'm like gotta get this right
you know okay so you know that the
character I'm playing Captain
Christopher Pike was originally played
by Jeffrey hunter who died way too young
and his son Chris hunter came to
comic-con just to meet me and tell me
that his father would have approved and
that meant I mean I'm also I'm almost
getting choked up talking about it that
meant so so so much Chris if you're
watching thank you I wish you were here
we made sure to introduce him during our
panel at Comic Con and like without a
doubt there was no there was no second
place that was that was the most
incredible moment there were things that
happen we've got to go to the Commission
in Las Vegas and there were things that
people said about how much star trekkin
change their lives and there was one
person in particular who literally said
that it saved his friend's life that his
friend was having some suicidal thoughts
and he took his friend and he sat him
down and he watch he was like let's take
take you through some of these episodes
to talk about really deep personal
things and it just helps Brown him and
literally save his life to be witnessed
and part of something that does that for
people Israel
is overwhelming I think it's the tattoos
you know when somebody comes up with a
tattoo it's like this is your character
I'm like that's for the rest of your
life okay that's a huge compliment but
you're taking up that much real estate
on somebody's skin because of something
you did I love it I love it well yeah
now I have to put that person behind the
lens of the camera when I'm playing in
the show like it's just all for you baby
yeah do you like being back in the south
it's an invigorating ride